podcast
[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'avis d'avant le nouveau
podcast de Lina je suis Clara et chaque
semaine je vous emmène dans la vraie vie
d'avant ça ressemblait à quoi d'être
jeune dans les années 60 c'était comment
la vie de couple dans les années 50
comment faisait-on la fête dans les
années 80 bref c'était comment la vie
avant les équipes de Lina ont épluché
pour vous des décennies de radio de JT
et de micro-trottoir elles en ont tirées
les meilleures archives pour aller à la
rencontre du quotidien des générations
passées je vous donne donc rendez-vous
chaque samedi sur toutes les plateformes
d'écoute pour découvrir les rencontres
les plus drôles les témoignages les plus
surprenants et les confessions les plus
touchantes à très vite
[Musique]